Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host as always Ricardo Loops. And
today I'm joined by Dr Mia Massimi. She is
Professor of Philosophy of Science in the Department of
Philosophy at the University of Edinburgh, affiliated with the
Higgs Center for Theoretical Physics. She works in the
area of history and Philosophy of Science with the
focus on the physical sciences. And today we are
focusing on her book Perspective of Realism, which by
the way, just recently won the 2023 Lacas awards.
So Dr Massimi, welcome to the show. It's a
big pleasure to everyone.
Thank you so much for having me Ricardo to
be here.
OK. So to get into the book, I would
like to start by asking you this. So what
is realism in science? And by the way, uh
when, when I mean, realism is, are there different
kinds of realism or not?
Sure. Yeah. So um what we call realism in
philosophy of science is really um a broad um
family of views um that normally are characterized by
um series of commitments um that um are distinctive
of what we would like to think of a
realist position. Now, uh what those commitments are obviously
um are fairly well understood, but also change in
a very subtle way depending on which specific variety
of realism one is willing to subscribe to. Um
So I would say that what defines realism are
two main commitments. Uh One is the idea that
there is uh uh uh uh some relationship between
science and um nature that is usually captured by
the notion of truth. Um And the other is
that there has to be some kind of representational
relation between how science and scientific theory, scientific models
relate to the target system. So if you ask
me, I would say um realism is defined by
those two broad notions of truth and representation. Now,
obviously, we may disagree about what we mean by
truth. We may disagree slightly about what we mean
by representation, how models represent reality. Um So, depending
on how different philosophers characterize those notions, you may
get different varieties of realism. Um So, over really
the past uh 40 50 years, there has been
a proliferation of views that call themselves or style
themselves as realist view. Um Some of them are
um redefining some of those notions of truth. So
you have variety of pragmatic realism or internal realism.
Um Others are rethinking the exact nature of the
relationship between science and nature um uh in terms
of representation. So you have varieties of selective realism,
for example, that um endorse the presentational commitment, but
they would be selective about which aspects of reality
the model is committed to represent. So very broadly,
truth and representation are the two key commitments. Uh
And within the broad umbrella, there is a, a
full spectrum of views that may slightly differ in
how they understand those two notions and how those
two notions enter into um our way of thinking
about science and, and reality
and related to that, what would an anti realist
stance in science entail?
So, um going back to this idea that, you
know, truth and representations are some of the two
key commitments. Um uh ANTI realist view views and
plural can be characterized by uh playing down some
of those um notions. So for example, you find
the varieties of instrumentalist views, they are anti realist
views because they are not committed to the notion
that um uh truth is any important element in
the way in which we think about the relation
between science and reality. Um You get varieties of
constructivism um that likewise uh would challenge the idea
that uh representation really plays an important role in
how models latch onto, onto the world on the
realities. Um So there's a broad spectrum of views
really going back to um 1980 the scientific image
of Basman Pras. And um that has been a
landmark book for a constructive empiricism. Um It's a
classic example of an anterial view where um the
notion of truth is replaced by notion of empirical
adequacy, for example. So according to a fra and
die of science is not to deliver um theories,
they are approximately true but to deliver theories, they
are pi adequate. Um TWO more recently varieties of
epistemological constructivism. So, um Mike Boone um building on
the process and defense form a form of constructivism
and um how she conceptualizes the relationship between models
and reality. Um So this is just an example,
but obviously the family is much broader than that.
And what is a scientific perspective?
Um So it's a great question, what is STV
perspective? So the term um has a bit of
an history. Um The way I've been using it
in my book um really has a um a
predecessor. The closest predecessor is in Ron's uh book
on scientific perspective is uh the way Ron Giri
originally defined the notion of a scientific perspective was
really in analogy uh with Thomas Coon's notion of
a disciplinary matrix. So disciplinary matrix is a um
a slightly more refined notion of uh probably the
more familiar notion of S and TV paradigm um
in the sense that it indicates uh a family
of um practices and commitments that particular community has
at a particular historical time. The way in which
Rangiri originally defined the Oslo scientific perspective in, in,
in the book was really in terms of families
or models. So Rangiri was building on a long
standing tradition, going back to Patrick Sap in the
19 sixties onwards, um whereby uh we need to
think of scientific theories as, as families or models.
Uh STARTING with high level models, uh representational models,
going all the way down to um models of
the experiment, data model and so forth. What I
do in the book is to slightly move away
from Maroni's definition. Um Because I would like to
think of a scientific perspective as something broader than
just the family of models. So for me, a
scientific perspective is the historically and culturally situated practice
of particular communities, a particular historical time. And I
understand really this notion of practice in a very,
very broad sense um um to include varieties of
knowledge that um may not necessarily have well defined
formalized modeling practices. Um So broadly speaking, a scientific
perspective is a, is a historically situated practice of
a community. And um here I borrow on the
literature in epistemology. Um THERE'S been again, a very
important literature on perspective is coming from epistemology and
Aaron Sosa in particular knowledge in perspective uh book
uh from which I'm drawing in thinking that really
what SN TV perspective does is not just to
um advance um a series of claims of knowledge,
but also provide the um experimental theoretical and technological
tools for reliably making those claims of knowledge as
well as providing um methodological and epistemic principles that
can justify the reliability of um of our uh
uh uh uh practices for making those claims of
knowledge. So it's kind of a a three fold
distinction between the body of claims of knowledge, the
experimental theoretical conceptual tools to reliably make them and
the methodological epistemic principle that justify the reliability of
those uh of those tools. And that's the, the,
the very broad way in which I've been using
the term in the book.
And what about a perspective of realism? What does
it mean exactly? And what flavor of realism applies
to it?
So, um yeah, that's a great question. Going back
to the original question about varieties of realism and
family of realism. Um I'd like to think of
prospect our realism as a view that is committed
to the notion of truth as correspondence and the
idea that um our theories, our models especially uh
represent reality. So it's a realist view. But the
way I present the view in the book is
that it, it's not a metaphysics first uh view
about realism. So very often what you find is
that realism is defined by uh metaphysics first approaches.
So if someone declared themselves a realist, what they
really mean is that they are committed to spelling
out to what the metaphysical building blocks of nature
are or they are committed to um tell a
story about uh what the metaphysical foundations of reality
are. And the metaphysical story typically involves um different
flavors of metaphysics. So some people are committed to
natural properties others are committed to the there are
dispositions um or other people believe in causal powers.
Um PER the realism is not a metaphysics first
approach in the sense that although there is a
metaphysical part, uh which is the second part of
the book, um the primary aim is really um
trying to uh uh in a way show how
that metaphysical commitment is really downstream to an epistemological
project. So what really matters to me is to
trying to understand how we produce reliable knowledge over
time and how a plurality of historical and cultural
situated perspectives um are able to uh deliver that
reliable knowledge over time. So um I see realism
not so much as uh um an exercise in
trying to uh unveil the metaphysical building block of
nature, but I see metaphysics as the downstream outcome
of how we tell a story about how we
produce reliable knowledge over time. So there is a
metaphysical part. So ultimately, spec of realism is realism
about phenomena about modally robust phenomenon. And that obviously
involves really finding the very notion of phenomena that
has a long philosophical history. And it's, it's, it's
part of what they're doing in the second part
of the book. So if you ask me, what
kind of flavor is perspective, a realism, it's really
realism about moderate robust phenomena. Um But as I
said, I see that metaphysical commitment as, as the
outcome of uh um uh a more important exercise,
which is trying to understand how um different communities
over time and culture produce reliable knowledge over time.
But then where is, where exactly is the perspective,
all nature in scientific representation?
So, yeah, what that perspective is enters into the
story of how we produce reliable knowledge, right? So
um I can think of a plurality of communities
that are historical and cultural situated, different historical periods,
different cultures and so forth. Can we tell a
story about how that knowledge is produced a across
these different communities? And how is that story going
to look like? Um So one thing I definitely
wanted to do in the book is to avoid
any um standard template that you find in the
literature on realism about realism of being some kind
of convergence to a reality that um in a
way we all agree upon. Um There is no
convergence in perspective of realism. Um The way I
use often this metaphor in the book taken for
um the, the o Borges at the Garden of
Forking Path, they are uh producing knowledge is a
bit like going through a garden of forking path
and kind of zigzagging where at each juncture, we
have to make a choice about which path we
want to go down. So there is no uh
or underlying picture, the realism is a convergence to
because really it's a realism about phenomena, there's no
realism about any fundamental metaphysical reality, as I said,
the cause of powers, dispositional essence is that we
want to call it. Um So those phenomena are
encountered by different communities across different periods and across
different cultures um in a reliable way or in
a way that we are able to uh uh
to see how their situated practices intersect with one
another. So this is where the perspective that comes
in, right? Because traditionally, um the very idea that
the starting point of conversations about realism um is,
is, is, is is human beings in their plurality
and historically and cultural situated, this has appeared to
be a stumbling block to any realist project. How
could one ever possibly defend realism, especially about science?
Once we take really seriously that there is a
plurality of um historically situated communities and their culture.
So that was the starting point of my um
kind of journey uh for the book. Um I
went back to the notion of representation. I said
at the beginning through the representations are the two
key commitment of any realist view. And I wanted
to understand what makes some representations pers respectable and
whether there is a way of reconciling the perspective
of representation with realism. Um So at the very
beginning of the book, I go back to the
analogy between art and science and that has been
well explored since the time of, well, it's a
long story, long tradition really. Uh BUT more recently,
Basra and 2008 book on a scientific representation, paradoxes
of perspectives has been a very influential uh book
for uh for my own personal journey, but also
Kathrine Elgin uh 2017 book. Uh True Enough, uh
is also very important for discussing the perspective nature
of representation. And so really thinking about the analogy
between art and science, what makes some representation perspect?
Traditionally, we tend to think of that uh question
in terms of the representation is situated is from
a particular vantage point. So um a drawing, a
perspective drawing is what makes the drawing perspective is
that the scene is painted from a particular angle.
And obviously, the angle means that there are other
aspects of the scene that we can't really see
uh from that particular angle. So there is an
element of lusion and there is what Vansen called
um a horizon of alternatives. We could have chosen
to represent the scene from different angles and we
could have chosen to represent the object with different
attributes. Um So the story I turn in chapter
two and three of the book, which is really
the beginning of the of the book is that
very often that specific way of thinking about perspective
of representation um has been um regarded as a
as a, as a difficulty for any realism or
a realist project. Um Precisely because if the representation
is situated is from a particular angle, how can
we ever be in a position of saying what
the real nature of the object is, our knowledge
is always partially occluded and, and, and, and not
complete. Um So the story I tell is that,
well, actually, if you look at the nature of
perspective and drawing in art, um there are two
ways of thinking about perspective, um a representation is
perspective, not only because it's drawn from a particular
angle, but because it's also drawn towards one or
more vantage point. Actually, technically, this is the definition
of a perspect uh representation that um there is
one or more vantage point towards which lines converge.
And that's what creates the optical illusion that you
can see a three dimensional space on what effectively
is a two dimensional canvas. Um And, and so
I play with that metaphor in art to say,
well, really, those are two aspects of the same
coin really, you know, you the representation is perspect
as drawn from a particular vantage point only in
so far as there is one or more vantage
points that allows us to create this, this these
windows of reality, uh this, this three dimensional space
emerging out of a two dimensional canvas. And so
that's my entry point for the idea that there
is a way of telling a story about realism
starting with the situated nature of the representation.
So tell us now about the notion of pluralism.
Where is it and how does it apply to
science?
Yeah. So pluralism is really uh again, a big
family of views. Uh I'm drawing really here on
a long standing tradition that has emphasized the importance
of pluralism in science. Um EXPLANATORY pluralism and methodological
pluralism uh tradition. Going back to Ellen Longino and
uh Carol, a fair and Miriam Solomon and Sandra
Mitchell, integrity, pluralism. Obviously, John Dupre promiscuous realism and
many, many, many others. Um THE kind of pluralism
um that matters to my story is again, perspect
about pluralism is pluralism of perspectives as I have
defined it. Uh So my emphasis is not so
much on um explanatory methodological or ontological pluralism. It's
really pluralism about uh uh historically, cult is the
practices. It's, it's a fact that science is the
outcome of this plurality of perspectives and communities that
have endorsed different practices. Um And then obviously, then
the question becomes OK. Um As I was just
saying with the problem of perspective or representation is
pers sorry, representation from a point of view, representation
uh uh towards one or more vantage point, the
question is OK, if you take the pluralism as
a fact about science, what kind of uh realism
emerges out of that, can we even talk about
realism or should we just say that we are
um confined to a plurality of um ways of
knowing they are distinctive of different communities and their
practices? Um But we can't really attempt to tell
a story about science and scientific knowledge and, and
realism about science and the best that we can
do is this plurality of scientific practices. So, what
I do in the book is to say, no,
no, no. We, we can take the pluralism, perspect
of pluralism as a starting point. It's a fact
about science. The science is produced in that way.
But that doesn't mean that we need to end
up with some kind of instrumentalist or anti realist
view. There's still a way of defending realism in
science. Um STARTING with perspect about pluralism.
Mhm And so another thing that you tackle in
your book is the problem of inconsistent model. So
what is that problem really about and can perspective
is help us tackle it?
Yeah. So kind of zooming into uh this problem
of how to reconcile um Perspect about pluralism as
pluralism of perspectives and, and realism. The problem in
consistent models uh is, is, is one of, is
one of the major problem for any perspective is
um because this is where we the pluralism um
appears to be somehow at odds with any realist
claim. Um So it's a problem that was really
brought to the general attention um maybe 13 years
ago uh roughly uh by uh Mary Morrison um
in a, in a beautiful paper where she discusses
the plurality of models in some areas of science.
So she says, well, look at nuclear physics, right?
Um So the areas of science where there is
one model, we all agree more or less that
uh you know, it is the um best model
to describe some kind of phenomena. But there are
other areas where there seems to be a pluralism,
a kind of endemic pluralism and as, as pluralism
of models. So the example of Morrison is that
if you look at nuclear physics, and if you
ask the question about what is the atomic nucleus,
um you find different answers to the question depending
on whether we are studying a nuclear fission. In
which case, we represent the nucleus as if it
was a liquid of incompressible nuclear fluid. Uh But
if we are studying um stellar nucleus synthesis, we
use different families of models, the cluster model whereby
the atomic nucleus is represented as a tetrahedron with
a particular structures of problems and neutrons. And obviously,
if we're studying other phenomena in high energy physics,
we use yet another class of models. We use
the quark models to describe what happens when we
smash protons to say at LHC. So Morrison Point
was, well, if we have this pluralism of models,
does it even make sense to ask what is
the atomic nucleus? I mean, w where is the
realism there? Right? I mean, we have different stories
about what the nucleus is. Um IS there one
which is the best one? And if, if there
is, then what about the others? Isn't it better
to adopt some kind of instrumental is um perspective
is, has often been accused of being a form
of instrumental is so um Morrison uh argument in
that paper that has also been rested by other
philosophers like an Chakravorti, for example, in um in,
in, in, in, in his book on um the
the kind of metaphysics of nature is that very
often perspective is, doesn't live up to the promise
of realism because it looks like uh what we
really mean by perspective is is the representation is
drawn from a particular point of view. So if
you look at the nucleus from the point of
view of um fission, then it looks like a
liquid drop. But if you look at the nucleus
from the point of view of stellar nucleus synthesis,
then it looks like a tetrad. And I think
it's that way of thinking about perspective is that
has really um meant that perspective is for a
long time as has been regarded as kind of
no much for realism. Um So I tackled the
problem of inconsistent models in chapter three of the
book. And um I show that the problem is
not really a problem for perspective is in so
far as we are clear about um some hidden
assumptions that seems to be creeping into the argument.
And so some of those assumptions are uh in
my view are, are really um kind of very
demanding and unduly stringent realist assumption that seems to
assume that models represent by mapping 1 to 1
aspects of the model with aspects of the target
system. And that seems to understand the notion of
truth going back to representation of truth in terms
of uh truth maker. So there has to be
a ontological state of affairs in terms of ascription
of essential properties to particular that make some claims
of knowledge true. And now if one endorses that
view about truth, the truth makers and representation as
mapping, I think Morrison has a point that this
plurality of model seems to be a problem for,
for realism, we can't think of the nucleus as
having inconsistent or incompatible essential properties. Um But what
I do in chapter three of the book is
to resist that assumption and saying, uh why, why
do we need to buy into representation as mapping
or what do we need to buy into truth
as truth maker? Maybe there is a different way
of thinking about what models do and how they
represent from a perspective or point of view that
doesn't necessarily land us into this um uh quo
of inconsistent essential properties ascribed to the same target
system. And so it's a very important problem because
it's really um the starting point of a way
of reconciling realism or perspective is
and uh related to perspective modeling and perspective of
models. Um What do you mean by them being
blueprints on reality as you say in the book?
And uh perhaps related to these, how do the
concepts of conceivability and possibility enter into it.
Yeah. So um what I do from chapter four
or five onwards is to spell out the positive
story, right? And not just to say, we need
to resist all this assumption and duly stringent assumption.
So um a different way of thinking about what
models do is to tell a different story about
how to represent their target system without ascribing essential
properties to the target system. So in that context
that develop the view that models really are inferential
blueprints, so they are blueprints that allows different communities.
And again, think of a plurality of historical and
cultural situated communities to draw inferences about relevant model,
robust phenomena from a plurality of data set. So
what the model does is not so much mapping
1 to 1 aspects of the model and aspects
of reality. I think we have been very often
in philosophy, science, we have this picture that models
represent. But as if really the primary function of
the model was to mirror a map onto the
target system, right? But that idea seems very counterintuitive
to me even I mean, think of well established
model like the DN model of the nucleus, right.
I mean, we don't, we don't use the model
because we want to necessarily represent the nucleus, we
use the model because we want to make inferences
right about the that we want to study, we
want to understand how DNA behaves, we want to
understand how uh possible error in the um in
the in the process of DNA uh uh chain
of events may happen. So we, we want to
ask those questions about what is possible about DNA
replication and mistakes in the DNA replication. So think
of models really as catering to this needs of
allowing us to make uh uh relevant and appropriate
inferences about phenomena that we want to study. So
that's what the metaphor of inferential blueprint is. So
models yes, do represent and do represent from a
specific vantage point. That's why we have a plurality
of models used by different communities. The primary function
is not to ascribe essential properties to the target
system. As the metaphysicians would like us to think
of the primary function is to allow communities to
make reliable, robust, relevant and appropriate inferences about those
uh uh those phenomena that, that, that we want
to study. And so again, I use the analogy
very often as I do in the book between
um uh uh uh perspective of representation in this
case in architecture. So the idea of the inferential
blueprints is borrowed from, from architecture because again, in,
in, in, in architecture, you can have uh um
a plurality of perspective or representation of say a
house that allows different communities of the carpenter and
the masons and the architects to work together and
make inferences about how the house should be built.
How tall should the roof be? What's the relationship
between the height of the door and the height
of the roof. Uh And so I use an
analogy to say likewise, whenever we want to study
specific phenomenon, that plurality of models allows these different
communities to make those uh uh relevant and appropriate
inferences about the objects so that we want to
study. Um So they find in models as really
catering to um the need of delivering knowledge about
what is possible about the object under study. So,
perspect modeling is modeling possibilities, modeling, how things could
be. Um And it's, it's a way of answering
those questions in a kind of very exploratory way
where we have not just one community that can
reclaim full ownership of the knowledge of the target
system, but we need a plurality of communities that
I illustrate with various case studies in the book.
So I have one chapter on climate change. So
climate modeling in the context of studying um uh
global warming, one chapter on developmental psychology and one
chapter on the nuclear physics where I show how
in each case to study specific phenomena like the
stability of some nuclear or difficulties with reading or
global warming. We need a plurality of community. So
if you want to study climate change and global
warming, you need a plurality of people that model
um increase in ocean heat temperature uh communities that
model how glacier and permafrost are changing under the
effect of greenhouse gasses. Communities that study corals and
uh uh tree rings. So then thema again to
make inferences from those data to the phenomena under
study. And so it's through that plurality of modeling
practices and, and communities that we come to know
very complex and multifactorial phenomena like um global warming,
for example. So that that's how I use the
analogy with models as inferential blueprint to explain our
models. Yes, represent, yes, represent from a perspect point
of view. But they do so by effectively delivering
knowledge about what is possible concerning the object that
we want to study.
So earlier in our conversation, you alluded to this.
Uh But what are they, what are phenomena and
what is the relationship between them through this framework
of perspective of realism?
Yeah. So um going back to uh exactly the
question of what flavor of realism is basically our
realism, as I mentioned in the beginning, it's really
a realism about phenomena. But I, one of the
main task of the book was to redefine what
I mean by phenomenon. This phenomena come from a
long standing empi traditions that really stretches back to,
you know, pm 19 05, a wonderful book on
to save the phenomenon more recently, wasn't to Pras
and I mentioned already in 1980 scientific image. Um
THAT also defends the view that um you know,
the reality is reality made of phenomena observable phenomena
according to Tora. Um So it's very difficult to
say that I'm a realist about phenomena when the
very term phenomenon has been associated with uh a
long standing and pis tradition that is normally regarded
phenomena is not the sort of objects that one
would have real and commitment to. Um So what
I do in the second part of the book
is trying to um articulate the positive story and
the positive story is that um given this perspect
of pluralism, uh where models are embedded as part
of the practices of different communities, the inferences that
we make are inferences to what I call moly
robust phenomena. So what are moly robust phenomena? They're
not the phenomena of the fro and they're not
the phenomenal of Pierre do m they're not the
phenomena of the Empire tradition as um faint copies
or faint images of a reality uh that lies
underneath the phenomenon that we need to discover uh
you know, appealing to the metaphysician tools or whatever
dispositional essences or because of powers uh phenomena of
what there is in a way I'm um borrowing
from the country and tradition, the idea that knowledge
is knowledge of phenomena, but those phenomena not in
pieces, phenomena more robust. And what I really mean
by more of robustness is that phenomena stable event.
So there's a kind of 22 tier ontology that
I articulate in chapter six of the book. So
phenomena are stable event index to a particular domain
and they are modally robust across a plurality of
data to phenomena inferences. So there are stable events
in that, that there is a level of reality
that are called stable event where stability is really
synonymous with low likeness for me. So um stable
events are events that are such not because they
are core ones, but because there are low like
dependencies in in the fabric of those events. So
that explain why they are stable. But the phenomenon
is not just a stable event. Uh The phenomenon
is the outcome of an inference made by communities
from data understood broadly as empirical occurrences. So to
give an example that I um given the book,
um it is a stable event that an electric
charge is gonna be affected by an electric or
magnetic field. So there are low like dependencies that
explains how an electric charge is going to be
deflected by an external field, that's a stable event
in nature. But what we called um cathode ray
or the phenomenon of the bending of cathode rays
is the model robust phenomenon that uh was discovered
by JJ Thompson at the end of the 19th
century using a a particular tool that was a
cato tube working in a particular historically cap situated
context. There was the Victorian Cambridge of the end
of the century. Um And, and so the phenomenon
is not a robust because we can infer and
Reiner um the same phenomenon from different kind of
data sets by slightly tweaking the experimental conditions. Uh
And and so forth. So the model of robustness
is some kind of secondary property that is really
a property of how different communities are able to
robustly infer the same phenomenon from a variety of,
of data. So that's broadly speaking, the kind of
phenomena for so that I I defend in, in
the book
and with that in mind, what are natural kinds
and how do we go from phenomena to kinds?
So yeah, Um so, one of the problem I
had when I was writing the book is that
I was obviously committed to defending this phenomenon for
so, but I was also very much aware that
when it comes to realism, um it's not enough
to say that we live in a world where
there are moli robust phenomena, the bending of the
cat race, the decay of the Higgs boson, the
growth of the mycelium echolocation in Beluga. Those are
examples of what I call moli robust phenomena, the
pollination of flowers and so forth that require inferences
on behalf of communities to stable events in nature.
A realist wants uh something more than phenomena. A
realist want something about natural kinds. So a realist
would say, um I don't just want to know
what the bending of cadore is. I want to
know what the electron is. I want to know
what the nucleus is. I want to know what
genes are. I want to know, you know um
what lemon and zebras and supernovas. Are so those
are natural kinds. So those are uh kinds of
things. And um again, realism very often has been
associated with um number of views about what national
kinds are. Um RANGING from hacking. And no, to
I mentioned already, John Dupre promiscuous realism to varieties
of uh uh um microstructure and essentialism back to
Hillary Patnam in the 19 seventies and so forth.
Um So the story I tell in the book
about natural kinds, which really a long one, it
stands from chapter seven to chapter 10 in the
book is that natural kinds are open ended grouping
of historically identified phenomena. There is nothing more, nothing
over uh natural kinds than open ended grouping of
historical identified phenomena. And obviously, the big challenge is
OK, is this just a form of conventional, is
a natural kind, just the label that we attach
to grouping of phenomena. So I had to go
into um quite a lot of details to clarify
why the view is not a conventional view. And
it's not an essentialist view either. Um But it's
really a view that tries to again bring in
the inferential is so phenomena, the outcome of inferences
likewise natural kinds are the outcome of inferences. Um
Rob robust, reliable, still revis still open ended, still
very valuable inferences made by plurality of communities over
time. Um And so I'll give a full definition,
I give a full inferential story uh about national
kind. They are called natural kinds with the human
face. Borrowing from Hillary but 1990 book realism with
a human face. Um What I explain how those
law like dependencies in the fabric of the stable
events provide effectively the um I I if you
like the the kind of pointers in this walking
in the garden of working path in whereby communities
can make uh choices about what to cluster or
what not to cluster into the natural kind. But
to do so reliably, they need to rely on
low like dependencies. They are part of the stable
events in nature. So the clustering is not arbitrary,
it is not conventional. And so there is an
element of contingencies, but it's not a rampant kind
of contingentism. It's, it's kind of constrained and guided
by um low like dependencies in nature. So it's
a long story from chapter seven to chapter 10.
And I give a full detail of that in,
in, in, in chapter 10 of the book where
I delve into the historical case studies about the
electron. And yeah, sorry.
No, no, no worries. Uh And another thing I
would like to ask you is at a certain
point in the book, you talk about contingentism. So
what is contingentism and how is it involved in
perspective of realism?
So continent is, is associated precisely with um with
this point I was making about how the um
open ended grouping of phenomena um is to some
extent contingent in the sense that we could have
cluster different phenomena under the National Kind Electron, for
example, um now continent, this historically has been a
very powerful uh argument coming from the history of
science against a very strong um the physical form
of realism. Um um So, I don't know lots
of people that contributed to this debate from has
Chang to cons for them. Also Joseph Laporte. Um
SO things could have gone otherwise, right? So Joseph
Laporte, in his book on Natural Con and con
change, tell us it is a beautiful story of
how, you know, we made a choice at some
point to include the dirty oxide into um the
natural kind water. But there was a choice in
a way that we made, we could have, we
could have gone otherwise. So that's the element of
contingentism. Uh I define a particular brand of contingentism
in the sense that um um um I'm not
that kind of full blown contingent is in the
sense that I don't think that things could have
gone entirely in a completely different way. Uh Precisely
because um the way I think a phenomena as
a stable event where stability is synonymous with low
likeness means that the inferences that communities make about
what phenomena goes with. What other phenomena are not
fully at our discretion, are not fully at our
women in a way we need to respond to
the Tribunal of Nature as a speaker, I find.
So um There are a lot like dependencies that
really guides those inferences that we make. Um So,
uh uh and uh and so I tell a
story about how um every natural kind is a
kind in the making. Uh SOME of those in
the making kind become empty at some point when
we discovered that maybe there's some violation of fundamental
laws. Uh So we believed in caloric, for example,
back in the 19th century, people believed that there
was a substance called caloric that was responsible for
transitional state from ice to say water to, to
steam. Um But some of the uh inferences that
people made about what are the phenomena that are
captured by the Nashua Khan Caloric uh were clearly
inferences that very soon revealed their limits. So um
reveal their limits because very often they were appealing
to um features of the phenomena that were simply
false. So, Sadiq Karno was one of the um
key people in the uh formulation of the KO
principles and the car cycle. So Ko believed in
caloric back in the first half of the 19th
century. And he believed that there was a substance
that was uh uh physically conserved whenever a hot
reservoir goes into cold reservoir. And then a new
cycle starts behind like a steam engine. Uh BUT
obviously, there is no conserve calor and there is
no conservation of caloric and there is no perpetual
motion machine and in fact, can be created using
that principle. So this is where we face the
tribunal of experience where we can't say we could
have had now in 2023 an Act kind caloric
still alive. And well, no, we couldn't have had
that right, because we soon stumbled into some problems
about some of those very phenomena that were identified,
identified as the phenomenon where caloric was, was at
work. And uh and the fact that there was
no conservation of caloric and if anything there was
dissipation, which was then captured by the concept of
entropy and so forth revealed the limits of those
associations. So, so kind of long winded answer to
your question, the contingentism means that although things could
have gone otherwise in how communities came to make
inferences about phenomenon connection between phenomena, things could not
have gone entirely in a completely different ways because
in a way, there are those constraints concerning low
like dependencies of the phenomena that uh really act
as pointers in the garden of working path about
which inferences we decide to go down to and
which inferences we decide to abandon at some point.
I
understand. So getting into the last part of our
interview, could you tell us now about multiculturalism and
cosmo cosmopolitanism? Science? I mean, uh is science a
multicultural and cosmopolitan enterprise? And what role do these
two things? Multiculturalism and cosmopolitan, cosmopolitanism play in science?
Yeah. No, thank you. So this is the final
chapter of the book and it's um um I
wanted to write that chapter because um I, I
thought the book was going to be complete without
a final discussion about what really um questions about
realism and perspective iss uh are doing in, in
this context. Um So very often in the debate
on realism, philosophers have appealed to the aims of
science. So it seems that, you know, we care
about discussion about realism and the realism and truth
and representation because we want to fundamentally um answer
questions about what is the goal of science and
what is the aim? Um And I thought that
perspective of realism was not really answering that question
about what the aim of goal of science is.
Uh WHAT perspective of realism does is to um
offer a different lens for thinking about realism in
science, starting with this plurality of situated communities. And
once you take that step, the next step is
to think of questions about duties and obligations in
science and rights in science. So no questions, aims
and goals. But actually what is science for who
produces science? Who has to benefit from science, who
can reclaim as their own a right to benefit
from scientific knowledge. So the first chapter in a
way, try to answer those, those questions which are
kind of more um ethical political questions about duties
and obligations in science. So, multiculturalism and cosmopolitanism are
again huge terms with a very long and often
difficult and vexed history that I wanted to use
to um exactly explain they, they called the natural
perspective of realism. Though it's, there's a perspective of
pluralism that like there's multiculturalism, there's this plurality of
historically situated communities that over time produce reliable knowledge
about more robust phenomena. But also an invitation of
not thinking about that situated nature of knowledge as
some kind of silo where knowledge is produced by
community in isolation from other communities. Or you know,
this is the um kind of picture that we
had again from, you know, the the tradition of
a Thomas K on scientific paradigms where there is
incommensurability. Um There's a period of crisis and scientific
revolution. Uh And I, I wanted to offer a
different story where it was really an invitation of
not to think of scientific perspectives as siloed. Uh
BUT to think of those communities and their interaction
in terms of what I call intersecting and interlacing
scientific perspectives, perspectives that over time, not only methodological
intersect to allow us to make more reliable inferences
about the phenomenon that we want to study. But
also over time, historically interlace like the um like
in a fabric, like in a piece of cloth
where you have the different threads that are historically
interlaced uh to produce knowledge that effectively is knowledge
that we can reclaim as, as, as knowledge that
belong to all of us. And obviously that open
up also the question questions about when is the
interlacing virtues? When is the interlacing going badly wrong?
Because there are exploitative practices or epistemic injustices in
the way in which some communities appropriate other communities
types of knowledge. So whose knowledge is it? Who,
who can be uh uh uh attributed authorship of
particular uh knowledge claims? So those are all very
big questions that I try to simply really map
out in the final chapter and I hope to
get back to. But the idea is that starting
with this perspective of pluralism and multiculturalism, we can
articulate a picture about scientific knowledge as reliable knowledge
uh that has to address important epistemic injustice about
what I call the severing and trademarking of knowledge.
And at the same time, has to result in
a broader picture of how knowledge is really knowledge
produced by uh uh by humankind for humankind. So
that no one should be excluded from benefiting from
it and benefiting from the advances of scientific knowledge.
So it kind of branches out into debates about
the uh right to science as a uh as
a right that is enshrined in the UN Declaration
of Human rights. So everyone is uh should benefit
from um scientific progress and scientific advancement, but it's
obviously not what happens in practice. The scientific knowledge
continues to be privatized, continues to be in the
hands of um few wealthy countries. So um as
I said it as a final chapter that um
I hope to get back to in terms of
my present and future work. But it kind of
shows the broader um um kind of social political
dimensions in which discussions about pluralism and perspective is
and realism play out.
And so my final question for today will be,
is science really about producing objective knowledge or knowing
what objective reality is?
Yes, is the answer in so far as we
are clear about what we mean by objective reality,
right? So uh if objective reality means that there
is one way and one way only to uh
carving natural disjoint, I mean, that's not what perspective
of realism would subscribe to. Uh BUT by objective
reality, we mean that there is a world of
stable events, Koli events uh to which our uh
multifarious inferential practices have to respond. That's, that's objective
enough. And so, yes, scientific knowledge, knowledge of objective
reality within the bounds of uh the historical and
cultural situated practices that we have, we don't have
any God's eye view, we don't have any view
from nowhere. But that doesn't mean that what we
have is just um a fragmented landscape of isolated
communities. What we have is a fairly remarkable uh
knowledge produced over time by different communities. And I
think it's something that uh I wanted to celebrate
in, in, in the book. And uh as I
said, it kind of opens up broader questions about
um who produces knowledge and who should benefit from
knowledge that is entangled in my mind with these
questions about objective reality.
Mhm. Great. So uh I'm leaving a link to
the book in the description box of the interview,
which is again, perspective of realism. Uh Doctor Massimi,
just before we go, would you like to tell
people where they can find you and your work
on the internet?
Um So I have my website which is www
dot mila mastery dot com. So, um uh um
that's where my um articles and books and activities
and projects normally are, are posted. Mhm.
Yeah. So thank you so much again for taking
the time to come on the show. It's been
a real pleasure to talk to you.
My pleasure. Thank you so much for having me.
Hi guys. Thank you so much for watching the
interview until the end. Please share it, leave a
like comment and hit the subscription button and if
you like what I'm doing and to keep the
channel sustainable, please consider supporting it on Patreon or
paypal even just $1 per month is already a
great help. The show is brought to you by
N Lights learning and development. Then differently check their
website at N lights dot com. I would also
like to give a huge thank you to my
main patrons and paypal supporters bugger Larson, Jerry Mueller
and Frederick Sunda, Bernard, Se Z OLA AEX, Adam,
Castle Matthew Whittenberg, Arno Wolf, Tim Hoy, Eric, Alan
John Connors Philip for Connolly. Then the Mere Robert
Wine in NAI Z Mar Nevs Colin Ha Simon
Columbus, Phil Kavanagh, Mikel Stormer, Samuel Andre Francis for
the nuns feral Ken Hal Herzog. Nun Jonathan lebron
Jars and Samuel Correa Eric Heinz Marc Smith J
Tom Hamel S Friends, David Sloan Wilson, Yasa, Desario,
Roman Roach Diego, Romani Charlotte Bli Nicole Barbaro, Adam
hunt Palos stas Sy Nale Bach Guy Madison, Gary
Gelman, Samo Zal Adrian Yi Paul Tolentino JB was
Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Brunner, Douglas Fry Franco
Bertolotti, Gabriel Pan Cortez Orli Scott Zachary Fish, Tim
Duffy, Sunny Smith, John Wiesman, Daniel Friedman, William Buckner,
Paul Giorgino, Luke Lo A Georges, the Chris Williams
and Peter Woz. David Williams the Costa Anton Erickson
Charles More Aex Shaw, Amari, Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, bangalore
atheists, Larry D Lee Junior Old Aring B Starry
Michael Bailey. Then Spur Robert Grassy. Zorin Jeff mcmahon,
Jake Zul Barnabas. Radis Mark Campbell Thomas Dubner, Luke
Neeson, Chris story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin Gilbert Jessica Nowicki,
Linda Brandon, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensley Man. George Coryat
is Valentin Steinman, Per Rowley Kate Von Goler, Alexander
Hubbard, Liam Dunaway Biard Masoud Ali Mohammadi and Perpendicular.
A special thanks to my producers is our web,
Jim Frank Luca Stefi Thomas Tom Ween, Bernard Nic
Ortiz Dixon Benedict Mueller Thomas Trumble, Catherine and Patrick
Tobin John Carlo Montenegro, Al Nick Ortiz and Nick
Golden. And to my executive producers Matthew Lavender, Sergio
Riano Bogdan Knits and Vege G. Thank you for
all.